while links as opposed that's flattery
coming from your southerner student
kneel to a pig if your daddy did we call
ourselves the free folk or at least most
of us won't kill you for calling us so
sound well I but that's just the way of
it in the true north beyond your great
white wall where your loss and kingdoms
end and men live free and I called for
we live close to our land and she's a
terrible wife failed to obey her and she
kills you on the frozen shore so deep is
the snow that men ride shariats made of
walrus bones pulled by packs of dogs the
hornfoots have it easy and mountains the
cold so hardens and blackens the soles
of their feet that I don't even need
boots the cave people spend their lives
in the dark doing cuts know what with
gods know who or what the thence have
one of the only nice bits of land a bear
a valley in the far north
Ned end of the frost hangs with game
copper and tin for shiny bronze weapons
better than the rusted old blades most
of us have with such advantages they
could be a generous friendly race
they're not as young boys they burned
her faces and rub ash and dirt into the
wounds scars more than their face I
think they follow their Mignogna
who's the kind of man who can rule these
kinds of men I know what you southerners
are thinking and know the Magnar is not
a king more like their God though not
want you to care to follow if you don't
sleep with your eyes open then there are
the Giants a proud race as old as the
frost things and about us tough they
speak too old tongue when they speak at
all though they understand more common
Don they're not a monster see you
southerners think once I was caught in a
winter storm so cold I knew it freeze to
death before he broke lucky for me
I stumbled on a sleeping giant cut open
her belly and crawled right up inside
her kept me warm enough but a stink
nearly done me the worst thing was when
she woke up she took me for her babe
suckled me for three whole moons before
I could get away Hey
aah but there's times I still missed the
taste of Giants milk I thank the gods
she was in a good mood and lacked a
husband an angry giant you want no part
of that whatever our differences one
thing unites us when we look south we
see hundreds of feet of ice piled high
manned by shivering crows in black
cloaks our wardens penning us a pair
warning us away from warmer lands softer
beds and prettier girls but the cold
winds are rising the hornfoots couldn't
stand against them no elephants no the
Giants first they kill you then they
send your dead against you we faced
extinction every one of us
but then Mance Rayder came to us and
rallied every nation of the free folk as
no man Avast he was a crow once and
knows your ways for thousands of years
we've sucked fear of your kind from our
mothers teat we've been on one side of
the wall and you on the other no more
one of these nights you're going to hear
knock on your front door you best not
answer
you